65 years after a little boy was found
dead inside a cardboard box please
finally have an identity for him
Philadelphia authorities announced
Joseph Augustus zarelli was identified
using DNA as well as genetic genealogy
techniques Joseph was just four when
investigators say he was beaten to death
the most recent process to identify him
started in 2019 when authorities exhumed
his body and used the modern DNA
analysis to try and find family members
they were able to track down his mother
and father who are now dead as well as a
few living siblings despite pleas for
people to come forward with information
when the boy was found in 1957 police
eventually ran out of leads their only
Clues were the boy's naked body wrapped
in a cheap blanket and put into a box
that once held a bassinet
the boy appeared to be malnourished and
his body bore the signs of recent and
past trauma
in his very short life it was apparent
that this child experienced Horrors that
no one
no one should ever be subjected to
when people think about the boy in the
Box a profound sadness is felt not just
because a child was murdered but because
his entire identity and his rightful
claim to own his existence was taken
away
Dina can you tell us more about how DNA
advancements are helping solve cases
like this
example because of the number of years
that has gone by no amount of
investigative witness interviewing would
have discovered this but the DNA was
able to identify him and perhaps it
might lead them to just if they find the
killer or find out what happened perhaps
there was somebody else's DNA that was
also left on the body that would be
really hopeful because I think not only
do they want to identify him they really
want to find out exactly what happened
and how he died of course this case is
not sold as yet so Terry what's next for
the investigation is finally finding out
how he died by whom is it is it easier
to find out this than to find out as an
identity well you know now that they
have his identity I think it will make
it a little bit easier to find out
exactly what happened we may not have
DNA evidence of the person who killed
him or the people who killed him but we
can now with a name Trace back his life
and that's where that footwork that
investigation is going to come in he is
the son of two different people now even
though they have already died we can go
back and look at what kind of life this
child had and the evidence and the you
know information that we have so far is
that he had bruises his body had been
battered and beaten not just at the time
of his death but apparently he had older
bruises in his body so I do think that
the footwork is going to be done here
and if in fact the siblings or some
other relatives are still around they
can be interviewed and perhaps they have
information that can lead the
authorities to some additional
information so that identity is critical
thank goodness we had that DNA
identified and hopefully one day soon
they will be able to determine what
happened to this young boy it's a tragic
case and it's a horrible way to go four
years old it's just really tragic
absolutely but we're glad that some
answers were made Dina Terry thank you
as always and thank you for joining us
here on Law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America